قد يبدو هذا وكأنه مقطع فيديو
لجندي حقيقي يطلق صاروخًا حقيقيًا على
طائرة تم نشره على X المعروف
باسم Twitter مع تسمية توضيحية تقول المزيد من القوة
لك يا
حماس ولكنه ليس حقيقيًا إنه في الواقع
مقطع من لعبة فيديو تسمى Arma
3 على الرغم من  أنه تمت مشاهدته أكثر
من نصف مليون مرة، فإن
المقطع الفيروسي هو مجرد واحد من العديد من
المعلومات الخاطئة التي انتشرت بسرعة على
المنصة في الساعات التي تلت
شن حماس هجومًا مفاجئًا ضد
إسرائيل بعد أن استولى إيلون ماسك على تويتر
العام الماضي.  إيقاف آلاف
الموظفين، بما في ذلك العديد من المسؤولين عن
مكافحة المعلومات الخاطئة على المنصة،
الآن للمساعدة في مناشدات المحتوى الكاذب،
وتعتمد الشركة بشكل كبير على
ملاحظات المجتمع، وقد أنشأ مستخدم جماعي
نظامًا للتحقق من الحقائق مثل هذا النظام الذي تمت إضافته إلى الجزء
السفلي من تغييرات ماسك
للتحقق على المنصة
يسبب أيضًا ارتباكًا قبل أن تكون الشارة الزرقاء
دليلاً على هوية الشخص أو المؤسسة كما
قال، ولكن الآن يمكن لأي شخص
شراء حساب تم التحقق منه
بعلامة اختيار زرقاء ويتم تعزيز هذه الحسابات
بواسطة خوارزميات X والأشخاص
الذين يديرونها لديهم حتى  فرصة
لكسب المال من
منشوراتهم، تتم مشاركة هذا الفيديو من خلال
حساب الشارة الزرقاء وتمت مشاهدته ما يقرب من
2 مليون مرة، حيث يُظهر الفيديو أن
مقاتلي حماس يأسرون
مسؤولين إسرائيليين كبارًا ولكن هذا غير صحيح،
فهو في الواقع مقطع فيديو للسلطات في
عيران تعتقل انفصاليين  القادة